[Music]
we bet we're the biggest fans of the
loud house ever we've managed to find
some amazing illustrations that will
show you what the young members of the
loud family will look like in the future
make sure you watch this video until the
end to see what Lana would look like as
a teenager
don't forget to like this video and
subscribe to our channel if you're a fan
of the loud house now let's look at ten
loud house characters reimagined as
teenagers Lily although we talk a lot
about her older siblings we never really
pay much attention to the 15 month old
Lily loud well all that is about to
change we found quite a few pictures of
what Lily loud would look like as a
teenager and although we have no idea
what her personality will be we can
imagine she will be just as unique as
the rest of her siblings but as we wait
for her to grow up we thought we'd give
you a little sneak peek of what these
talented artists think Lily would look
like in her teens the first illustration
belongs to a deviantART user Anton dis
who gave Lily a school uniform and cute
blonde hair J boy 32x also made a pretty
good version of what Lily will possibly
look like when she's Lincoln's age
doesn't she look adorable we loved that
he kept her buck tooth here's another
slightly older and much bolder version
of Lily designed by mr. Crabb x10 on
deviantART younger sisters love to
borrow older sisters stuff without
asking and you can clearly see her
sisters had a huge influence on this
version of Lily we could even spot
Lenny's sunglasses these illustrations
do make us wonder what personality will
Lily have in the future do you think
she'll be anything like her brother or
sisters Lisa the four year old Lisa loud
is the second youngest in the family but
she proves that age is not important
because this little one comes with
unbelievable intelligence that earned
her a Nobel Peace Prize
we love Lisa we've previously shown her
what she look like as a boy and as a
bodybuilder
but these illustrations of Lisa as a
teenager are some of our favorites
because she's so smart lisa is skipping
grades like nobody's business by the
time she's a teenager she'll probably
get a fancy scientist job we love her
but we also love these fantastic
illustrations check them out see Bart on
deviantART gave us a pretty good preview
of the four year old Lisa in her teenage
years with these fantastic pictures
usually Lisa is unamused by pretty much
everything but at 16 she is finally
smiling
we knew she'd come around been lulu-nee
also managed to recreate an awesome
looking teenage Lisa we also found this
illustration by the loud house fan who
decided to give Lisa a dress instead of
her usual green sweater
she's also cracking a small smile and
she put her hair up it's definitely
surprising to see a different side of
Lisa and we can't wait to see what
she'll actually look like as a teenager
we bet you'll only get smarter and
she'll probably be the world's most
famous scientist Lenny the 16 year old
Lenny is the second oldest of the family
but unlike her older sister she's much
more loving and caring toward her
younger siblings she's a fashionista of
the family and although she can be very
dizzy and naive we love her for her
carefree attitude
Lenny loud is already 16 but we found
some amazing illustrations that show her
in a slightly different teenage version
of the Lenny you know we all know Lenny
is stylish so here are some of the most
stylish photos we've managed to find
check out this variation created by
dragon Kyle 44 on deviantART mr.
cravaack Stan made Lenny slightly taller
and Dark Mirror emo 23 made her slightly
older and equipped with all her favorite
accessories but our favorite has to be
this teenaged version of Lenny done by
the loud house fan from deviantART who
added a sailor moon outfit to her look
we can definitely see Lenny modeling
fashion trends like this in her teenage
hood before settling on her current look
which is equally as cute we can't decide
which one of these illustrations is our
favorite but we can definitely tell
that Lenny is one of our favorite
characters see Bart also created this
slightly younger teenage lorry and it
looks like she's not yet added the
stylish sunglasses to her iconic look
who wouldn't want an older sister who's
such a fashionista but still good at
heart
Lynn as the sporty one of the family the
13 year old Lynne is the most
competitive if you have a lot of
siblings we bet there's at least one of
you who loves to turn everything into a
competition you're definitely not the
only one
Lynne is already a teenager but we
managed to find several versions of her
looking slightly older she definitely
still looks 40 we bet she's just as
competitive here she is looking as cute
as ever in her sporty outfit this image
belongs to the fresh knight on
deviantART who also decided to dress lit
up in stylish Yeezys see Bart give us a
whole timeline of what Lynn would look
like at different ages and we love her
look at 16 she seems more mature and
it's the first time we're seeing her
with her hair down and here she is as a
coach this illustration belongs to Jay
boy 32x and even though Lynn is 23 years
old on this picture we can see her
becoming a famous coach and make her
team win all championships at a much
younger age even though Lynn's
competitiveness can sometimes ruin the
family fun you have to admit the loud
family wouldn't be the same without her
she's so talented when it comes to
sports we bet she will become an Olympic
champion in more than just one
discipline Louanne of course we can't
forget about LuAnn when it comes to our
favorite loud house characters the
hilarious Luanne loud is definitely one
of our top five although all of them
have their own unique and lovable
personalities to the absolutely poll
arias even though our jokes sometimes
fall flat with the rest of her family
don't worry Luanne we get you luan is 14
years old but we'll show her in
different stages of her teenage hood the
first illustration belongs to Jay boy 32
X who made Luanne look taller but we
love that she's still wearing her
signature yellow outfit luan definitely
looks older here but we can see her
looking like this as a 17 year old see
Bart gave her slightly low
your hair but also kept her cute yellow
fashion look she looks about 15 years
old and she's totally adorable you can't
deny that LuAnn is one of the few
characters that can definitely pull off
that yellow outfit jump around jump jump
made her look younger but doesn't she
look like she's a lot of fun here's
another picture from this same artist
she looks awesome we can definitely see
LuAnn becoming one of the most popular
comedians out there and have her own
show even as a teenager of course we
still expect her to continue to annoy
her family with pranks and her hilarious
puns Lola the six year old Lola is a
pageant diva we can't help but love even
though Ms Lola is sometimes rough on her
siblings she's sassy and as hilarious
moments that make us love her she's one
of the girliest members of the family
who loves to dress up and of course show
off her beauty in pageants she's only
six years old so we found a few versions
of what she'd look like as a teenager
su parte showed us what Lola would look
like at 11 and also 16 we love how she
sticks to her signature pink color and
we bet she'll win over thousands of
pageants by the time she's 16 and while
we love her cute chip tooth at the age
of 6 it's interesting to see her full
smile at 16 nautical pudding on
deviantART also presented her at an
older age and we absolutely loved her
long blonde hair Jay boy 32 X made her
hair even longer and gave her a cute
pink headband while stratts turned her
into a real-life princess doesn't she
look like she'd be a perfect character
for the next Disney Princess we loved
her tiara her pink dress and the long
gloves she definitely looks a lot more
graceful than the feisty six year old
Lola we know from the loud house we
expect her to win all kinds of beauty
titles including Miss USA Lincoln can
you imagine having ten sisters with
unique personalities and being the only
boy in the family the 11 year old
Lincoln has always been our favorite
because we just can't believe he's
managing to survive the madness that is
the loud house of course he also wished
to have brothers but is seen that having
sisters is a much better option
Lincoln is just about to enter his
teenage years and we
at the loud house fans think he'll look
like our first two illustrations belong
to J boy 32x you can see Lincoln
definitely got taller in the first image
although the artist claims this is him
at 21 we do see some of his features
like his longer hair come out during his
teenage years the second image shows him
with Ronnie and his school crush who was
actually pretty mean to him until she
admitted she likes him we also found
this ridiculously cute slightly younger
version of Lincoln created by C Bart we
loved his chipped tooth and it looks
like his white hair is beginning to grow
out of control
Lincoln's personality is much more chill
than the rest of his siblings but we do
wonder what'll excel at later in life we
can see him take on jobs as a writer or
a video game developer as he loves
anything related to fiction the whole
family just in case we'll miss anyone in
this video here's an illustration was
done by the talented C Bart that shows
every single loud sibling at the age of
16 are they completely adorable
we love that lenio stayed the same but
the rest of them have either grown or
are looking slightly younger check them
out we have everyone from the youngest
and the family to the oldest doesn't
Lana look like Lenny and Lana and LuAnn
could practically be twins we also found
this illustration created by the
talented owner Eve on tumblr who
humanized the characters and made them
slightly more real some of them
definitely look like they've hit their
teenage years it's hard to believe that
this colorful family was once a family
of 25 rabbits
yes Chris Savino initially created the
loud house rabbit characters and
eventually change them to adorable
humans we know today this is precisely
why Lincoln has white hair and some of
them feature a buck tooth do you think
the loud house will be on the air long
enough for us to see the entire family
go through their teenage stage we'd love
to see an actual loud house family
portrait once they look older but it
looks like deviantART see Bart gave us a
pretty good preview we can't even
imagine everything they're going to
achieve once they're older Lucy Lucy is
only eight years old but she's already
going through a phase some of us went
through as teenagers
she's always dressed in
our clothing and she's incredibly moody
but we of course still love her we adore
her sarcasm even though she sometimes
scary-looking even to her own family
members although her older teenage look
is practically the same we do love this
version of Lucy check it out
J boy 32x reimagined her as a quite
fashionable teenage girl even though
she's still rocking her dark look on the
other hand CB arts version of Lucy is
slightly different while she still
features her signature dark clothing she
no longer has bangs that cover up most
of her face her hair is longer and she's
wearing a dress this deviantART user
also showed her in a dress we loved her
long dark hair and the black-and-white
sleeve covers and leggings we can
totally see Lucy looking like this when
she hits her teenage years master oh
yeah from deviantART also Illustrated
her in a unique way this Lucy sports
much shorter hair but it definitely fits
her look he calls her the Duchess of
darkness and it definitely is a perfect
title for this moody character do you
think her mood will ever improve or will
she forever rock dark clothing and
entertain us with her sarcastic cummins
Lana and we can't forget about the six
year old Lana who's probably the biggest
tomboy if he went through a tomboy phase
in your childhood we bet you can really
identify with her character Lana loves
to do all the dirty work her sisters
preferred not to do and she especially
loves playing in the mud she's only six
but we wonder if the teenage version of
Lana would still prefer to be a tomboy
rather than a girly girl we'll have to
wait to find out in the meantime here
are some amazing illustrations of what
Lana would look like in her teenage
years see Bart definitely thinks Lana
might look slightly less tomboyish when
she's 16 check her out she actually
reminds us of Wendy from gravity falls
on this picture
however nautical pudding reimagined what
Lana would look like at 14 and she's
definitely still rocking her usual look
you can even see mud spots on her shirt
like Lenny on deviantART Illustrated her
as a slightly different but still cute
version we love her pigtails Cruella
Deville 184 showed us what both Lana and
Lola would look like at 16 and we love
that both girls looks
nificantly taller of course Lana's still
rocking a red snapback it's hard enough
to choose a favorite loud sibling but
it's even harder to choose which of
these amazing illustrations we prefer
what do you think Lana would look like
as a teenager that's it for ten loud
house characters reimagined as teenagers
for more videos like this one check out
ten loud house characters all grown up
see you next time
[Music]